What up B?
This week we crackin
open one of my favorite books of all time-
The Brothers Karamazov by Fyodor Dostoevsky.
Fyodor Karamazov the shadiest cat you ever
known.
Fool don’t give a
sh** bout his three kids Dmitri, Ivan and
Alyosha.
All he care bout is stackin change, sippin
drank, and fu**in bitches all day erry day.
So some otha hustlas gotta snatch them kids
up to raise em right.
Years later tha bruthas all grown
up and Dmitri steps up to daddy demanding
his cash-money inheritance, but Fyodor does
his son straight dirty and keeps all dat cheddar
to himself.
So Ivan and Alyosha drop in and try to settle
this mess.
These days Ivan got rep for bein
wicked-smart, and Alyosha all churched-up.
Alyosha was ready to do some holy-rollin 24/7
up in dat monastery, but his teach Father
Zosima tell him he gotta go spread dat love
to tha world instead.
And speakin of spreading love, not
only do Dmitri and Fyodor got beef cuz o dem
grands, but they both got it bad fo some nasty
ho named Grushenka.
Later Alyosha drops in at Fyodor’s
spot where he peeps game at his daddy’s
servant Smerdyakov.
Word on the street is that this fool be the
result of Fyodor gettin shwasted one night
and not wrapping it up.
Ain’t nothin this scrub like mo
than hearin Ivan talk bout how if they ain’t
no God, playa can’t do no wrong.
Later, Alyosha and Ivan chillin when Ivan
be all like: “How can
there be a God with all this suffering, yo?”
Then he drops a sick poem on Alyosha’s ass
called “The Grand Inquisitor.”
Thinknin Grushenka bout to shack up
with his pops, Dmitri swangs over there to
whoop some ass.
After poppin Fyodor’s boy Grigory in his
grill, he steps up to pops ready to bang out.
Later, da fuzz bust in and accuse
Dmitri of icing Fyodor.
Dmitri say he didn’t do nuthin, but the
law don’t believe a word he say and toss
his ass behind bars.
When Ivan starts conversatin with
Smerdyakov bout the murder, Smerdyakov say
“Actually I killed him, bruh.
You said yourself that if they ain’t no
god, then anything goes, right?”
After dat, Ivan tweakin so hard that he gets
a visit from some clean-cut hustla who he
thinkin is THE DEVIL.
DAMN!
Whatever he’s on, I want some!
At Dmiti’s trial, Ivan still can’t
keep his sh** together and completely loses
his mind.
Then the jury convicts Dmitri and his ass
gets sent to Siberia.
After all dat depressing mess has
gone down, Alyosha tells some young’uns
that even though bad sh** happens, they just
gotta remember the good.
Naw mean?
Now unless you slow in the head,
you know that dis book’s title talkin bout
Fyodor’s fo’ kids Dmitri, Ivan, Alyosha,
and Smerdyakov.
And even though each of these hustlas got
they own flava, truth is, they all Karmazovs
through and through.
And when you rollin Karamazov deep,
you got a lust for life thats straight off
the chain.
See like his daddy, Dmitri all bout dem earthly
pleasures, which is why he always blowin cash
fast, tosssin
back henny, and throwin down with peeps fo
no good reason.
Livin it up big looks a lil
different for Ivan though- dat boy got such
a hard on for finding meaning that he drives
himself batsh** crazy.
Ivan always be aksin: If there’s so much
twisted- ass sh** goin on in the world, how
can there be a God?
And even if they is, I don’t wanna have
nuthin to do with his bent ass world.
But
like Dmitri say: A Karamazov is
either an angel or an insect.
And as da heart and soul of the novel, Alyosha
gonna keep it trill and fight the good fight
even in the face of the gnarliest suffering.
Like his street daddy Father Zosima
sayin: we’re all in this together B. You
can’t be lookin at the world like it’s
an empty meaningless place, cuz the only way
we’re gonna make it better is by gettin
eachother’s backs.
And the the best way to look out
for yo fellow homie is by preserving the good
in yo-self.
Cuz as Alyosha and Father Z preachin- it only
takes one true blue playa to plant the seed
of good up in this world.
So plant dat seed of good by hittin
dat subscribe button and checkin out the Thug
Notes store.
And be sure to check back next week for my
special episode on The Grand Inquisitor.
Peace, yall.